What a busy week we had.
Because we covered so
much ground this past week
and because we're almost at
the midpoint of this course,
I thought it would be
useful to summarize
some of the key
lessons from the week
and really one of the key
lessons from this course.
That lesson is very simple.
It is that our economies need to
continue to encourage and grow
what we call high
road firms that
are both good for
shareholders and for employees
if we are really to shape
the future of work that
works for all the
stakeholders in our economy.
How can organizations do this?
Well, it starts by having a
debate over the basic values
of the firm.
And you did that this week.
You took on the question
of whether this emphasis
on shareholder value, or what
we called financialization
view of the firm, is really
the only way in which firms
can compete.
And you answered
it very clearly.
You endorsed firms
that should be
accountable to multiple
stakeholders, to employees,
to societies, as well
as to their investors
and their owners.
And you noticed that there's a
wide variety of different forms
that organizations take, both
here in the United States
and around the world.
And in fact, the US is
one of the few countries
that emphasizes shareholder
value so heavily.
You also noted that it not
only varies across countries,
but even in the US
we didn't always
put such a heavy emphasis
on shareholder value.
There was a point in
time when we recognized
and that CEOs recognized that
they need to have organizations
that address both the interests
of the people who invest
in them, who own
them, but also they
were held accountable
to their employees,
to their communities,
and societies.
So we had this debate.
We have to keep
that debate going.
In the poll that you
answered, a vast majority [?
of you ?] endorsed the
stakeholder view of the firm.
So let's get on with it.
But you also noted that
there's no magic bullet.
There's no single practice
that high road firms can follow
to achieve these outcomes.
Instead, what we saw is that
there's a bundle of practices,
or what we call a
system of practices,
of employment practices,
operational features
of the organization,
business practices that
have to fit together
and be fitted
to the particular industries
and particular organizational
settings, particular
cultures and countries
in which they are embedded.
And this is just a list of the
basic things that we discussed.
That, yes, it starts by hiring
good, strong employees who
have good technical
skills and good people
in organizational skills so
they can work together in teams
and communicate with each other.
Then we invest in
training and development
and make sure that we create
a culture of respect and trust
at the workplace.
Provide employees with
a good opportunity
to improve operations
in the organization,
to bring their voice
into the discussion
so that their
interests are reflected
in organizational
practices themselves.
And then recognize
that you all want
good, flexible organizational
arrangements that
allow you to mix your personal
and your family and your work
lives, but to do it in creative
ways with modern technology,
with fair wages that are
linked, in some ways,
to productivity, to
performance, to the economy
of your organizations.
And where there are
unions involved,
we need to have
strong partnerships
between labor and
management, not
the traditional
adversarial relations.
When we do those things,
we get this bundle.
We get this system of
reinforcing practices
between the business
strategies that
are followed to create high road
organizations, the employment
systems, the operational
practices, and the workforce
culture.
So we know something
about how to do this.
And we know that this can
happen not only in traditional
profit-making firms or
public corporations,
but we discussed a whole range
of different organizational
forms--
family businesses
like Market Basket,
public corporations,
as we mentioned,
benefit corporations
like Patagonia,
employee-owned firms like my two
favorite breweries, New Belgium
and Harpoon, or in other
countries, IDEO in Sweden
and around the world.
There are examples of
employee-owned firms.
Community ownership-- Mondragon
in Spain and other countries.
And then my favorite football
team, the Green Bay Packers,
owned by the community
and maintaining
long-standing good relationships
with their stakeholders
and their environments.
We also discussed
whether it's possible
for global corporations to
hold to high road standards
in their supply chains.
We've got a lot of work
to do in this area.
It's clear that we
have a long way to go.
But companies and their
suppliers and NGOs
are all working on it.
So we recognize we can do
this in a variety of ways.
But I was particularly
excited and pleased
with the examples of high
road and low road firms
that you talked about in your
own assignments this week.
And you brought your
own personal experiences
as employees and sometimes as
customers into this process.
And here's just an example of
firms in the retail industry--
a family-owned firm, Wegmans.
That's a local one here
in the United States.
Whole Foods, which is known very
well, was used as an example
and compared with some other
organizations, one well known
and another one where we
just disguised the name a bit
in another country that
talked about the low wages
and lack of a living wage, not
particularly paying attention
to employee training
and development.
But also noting that even
in government agencies,
you had some very low road
firms or organizations
that favored their
certain employees
and didn't provide the kind
of feedback and opportunities
for growth.
But then there were some
libraries, hospitals,
government agencies that you
rated as high road firms.
The key point here is there's
no single organizational form,
and there's no single
model that says
you can only do this in some
sectors of the economy and not
others.
So I think we have brought
home this very key lesson
about the importance
of high road firms.
Our challenge now
is to make sure
that we figure out how to
spread them to larger numbers.
So this next week, it's time
to go on to the next subject.
We're going to take up
two critical issues--
entrepreneurship and
the role of technology.
And you've already started
those conversations
on the discussion forum.
So we'll continue them with some
really good videos and guest
interviews and material from
people all over the world,
talking about how we can use
technology to augment work,
not just to substitute
for work or displace work.
Yes, that's going to go on.
But pay particular
attention to what
our experts say we can do to use
technology to good advantage,
to augment and to support
good work in the future.
And then let's also discuss
how we can build high road
firms right from the beginning.
As entrepreneurs,
what do we need
to do to make sure that we
understand what it takes
to have a good
business model, to be
responsive to the
investors who are providing
the capital for these firms, but
also to make sure that we make
the choices about how we build
good jobs and careers for all
of the employees in
these new enterprises.
And let me make a final offer.
And that is, we're
almost about, as I said,
at the midpoint of the course.
And I'd like to use this weekend
to offer an open forum, sort
of office hours on the
discussion board, where
my team here for the course and
I will be available to answer
questions, to engage
in commentary,
to continue the dialogue
with you more directly.
So please take a look
at the discussion board,
participate with us,
ask us questions.
Let's use this as an opportunity
to see what we have learned
so far, to continue to
debate, even with us
if you disagree with us.
That's fine, too.
Let's have a good
discussion this weekend.
I'll make sure that I check the
discussion board periodically
over the next several days
and see what's on your mind.
And then, finally,
this weekend, we
will give you a short
evaluation to do us a favor
and give us a mid-course
evaluation on how
we are doing in the course.
So I look forward to continuing
the conversations this weekend
and in the weeks ahead.